I'm having a conversation
with Kristen on the patio of the coffee
shop block I used to run
that used to be the Coffee Bean and Tea
Leaf and now it's an Alfred's coffee
okay so it's better but you think it's
worse it's worse right it's better 99.9
of the population would say it's better
you are in the 0.1 percent that would
say it's worse okay because I'm a genius
and so so we're we're having a
conversation Kristen is looking at me
and I'm looking to her and I am facing
the street you know where this is going
I do I think I do yeah you get it
um
a car
pulls up on the street and stops because
it's at it's waiting for a red light
okay I'm talking to Christian she's
telling me something important actually
to where
I I can rack Focus behind her and I see
the window is open in the passenger seat
and inside is somebody staring at me and
as I rack Focus I see it's Bruce Willis
okay
question okay at this point you say oh I
didn't say that yet in your mind uh-huh
uh
uh in you how much and how quickly
rather did you absolutely know for sure
it was him instantaneously just
immediately it was immediately that was
desperate you know why because he was
looking directly at me I made eye
contact with him and he was he was
actually doing his Bruce Willis smirk
where he was like yeah I can't do it but
you know I'm talking about he's being
Bruce he's being Bruce Willis okay got
it so I she's telling me something
important and actually emotional okay oh
no so I'm seeing now I'm seeing Bruce
Willis oh God okay what a dilemma yeah
yeah so I'm like oh [__] I don't know
what to do that's terrible but and I
actually think I need to be here for her
but but she'd want to see Bruce Willis
but y'all also you got to be there for
Bruce too he's looking right at you
something's going on right so I'm like
now in my head I'm like is Bruce Willis
famous enough
to where I should stop this and tell
Kristen about it okay and because if it
was Barry Pepper I would just tell her
later afterwards no offense to Berry
pepper no we like we love you Giovanni
rabbisi I probably wouldn't do it either
no way anybody from save it Ryan from
Brian besides Matt Damon and Tom Hanks I
don't think I'd do it
so
so I'm like
I gotta say something and I say I'm
sorry babe but that's Bruce Willis yeah
he's one of the most giant movie stars
he's one of those giant movie stars of
all time there's no doubt you have to
stop and say yeah and I'm a huge fan of
him yeah you are yeah right yeah so I
say I'm sorry I'm sorry babe but that's
Bruce Willis and she looks over okay and
Bruce Willis is still staring directly
at me and how close are we talking to
him let's see uh how far would you say
that wall is over there 30 30 40 feet
okay so 35 yeah something like that 60
feet
twice oh that's close though yeah it's
very close yeah yeah okay so he's 60
feet away and then I I he's looking at
me and I say that's Bruce was I guess I
say it loud enough yeah which I really
didn't try to but a few of the people
around me go like this
so now yeah Bruce will look at me
everybody's looking at Bruce Willis okay
on the patio okay
so now I'm like I have to say something
I guess because I don't I don't know why
he's looking at me all right and he's
not looking away at any point he's just
staring no dude he is not looking away
at any point he's just staring at me
you're not weirded out even a little bit
very interested in what is happening
what is going on here yeah why is he
staring at me yeah did he just watch my
Netflix special it's like this kind of
thing where I'm like did he just see a
clip of mine or something or or do I
look like a guy that like [__] his ex
like this is always looking at me right
okay so I say to him
allowed because now everybody's kind of
involved in a way and I want to jump
past the part of awkwardness and I can
do it like this and I say
hey man
we all love you right and I say that
that loud because I want him to know
because I know he's also going through
that thing with with the brain fog and
all that he's doing well yeah he's not
doing so well but I gotta tell you
something he looks fantastic he looks
he's Bruce he looks fantastic but you
know you know you sometimes you see a
guy after you haven't seen him in a
while and you're like oh they look
really old yeah he looks great he looks
great okay so I say hey man we all love
you and everyone's looking at him and he
leans out of the car yeah
and he goes like this
whoa that much A lot
okay you told the story wrong dude
before you build it on text I know but
tonight how could I how could I get this
through text I there's no way just that
part voice noted I did yeah but so you
didn't do enough O's I wanted to do it
on the podcast all right then say that
I'm not sure so so and I and and that's
it and then
the guy who's driving him that looks
like Akon by the way is just like he's
he's going like this
pointing at me
and Bruce is like
and then
so he's literally that says no words no
words only Woos
that's and then later on I'm telling the
story Rick recalling it to Kristen and
someone else and Chris is like well he
was looking at me and I'm like oh dude
it's possible now
it's not how do you know
I guess maybe because her back was to
him right wow hey
come here and I was staring at him from
the beginning and end
she was here I was here Bruce was there
so when she turned around boom it looked
like she was looking back into the left
back and to the left but it looked like
he was looking at her obviously he was
looking at me because I [__] said the
thing and also it's looking at me in the
beginning so I get that okay no the best
part was no who's that guy from The Bear
the actor Jimmy Jeremy Allen White yeah
before the Bruce Willis thing
I walked by that guy
and I was looking at him as I was
walking by because when you're famous
and you see another famous guy you gotta
look at each other and be like
okay so I was walking by and I went to
go look at him and he didn't look at me
so I was like hey man
okay and then I went in and I got the
Bruce Willis thing uh maybe he didn't
see you though it was could have been
but but I walked right by him why and
then so jokes on him because I got the
Bruce Willis thing out yeah you you
don't even need him because you got the
biggest movies I was like yeah man that
sucks you know the bear guy didn't kind
of look at me and I was I was making
sure to I was ready for the famous to
receive the famous oh we are both in
this together you didn't even know his
name he's not on Bruce Willis's level so
yeah exactly and then and then I got the
Bruce Willis thing and then not only
that Bruce Willis was one that started
it and he also did the woo like for so
long according to you yeah was everyone
else like what is he doing no because
the whole thing was weird it was like
they were like I can't believe we saw
Bruce Willis okay for me there's another
day in the office you know but for
everyone else I get it wait but no I I
want to stick more with the crazy wooing
he did I don't know why he did that
did he really do it for that long I
might have been doing it maybe I did two
Woo's extra
he did a lot of moves why did they do so
wolves that was fantastic is that part
of his thing well no I don't think it
well I here's the thing it he did not in
any way seem out of it oh or incoherent
or anything like that
he just seemed like he was having a fun
time maybe he was on drugs I don't know
I mean I have no idea about any of that
but yeah so that's what happened damn
but Kristen thinks it was for it was for
her and I you know it's just like okay
anyway well that's my story all right
yeah that's a pretty good story yeah
thanks yeah oh the addendum I didn't
even take the addendum there's an
addendum there's an addendum I said that
there was gonna be an addendum oh okay I
thought that was okay yeah dude I'm at a
[__] grocery store today eating yeah
and I
I'm just eating I'm having a you know I
eat healthy I got Cod I'm eating Cod it
doesn't matter the story but I know it
doesn't matter yeah eating at a grocery
store yeah that's what I'm doing Cod at
a grocery store dude dude are you 78
the [__] eating Cod at a grocery store
the 78 years old
you know I I don't feel I don't feel
shame about it at all you shouldn't I'm
just saying that's yeah you're 78 okay
I'm with two other people okay okay
famous
you're with them yeah I'm with them
they're famous oh yeah okay so three
famous people but that doesn't matter
the story at all I know this matters I'm
calling it like a novelist talks about
the clouds when they're really the books
about the guy start
saying the parts that matter okay
I'm eating the Cod yeah
that doesn't seem like it matters but
but I kind of and I'm doing it and we're
having a conversation
Rumor Willis walks by his daughter
who we know this is a [__] Willis
like for me
just like a heavy Willis week to Willis
Fest is that the whole story
just weird right that's not weird that's
not weird really that's not weird not
really
they're two different people you know
they're in the same family dude yeah but
they're not yeah yeah you don't think
it's weird if one day somebody sees
matly and the next day they say crystal
yeah uh it's weird there we go dude
it's a little weird yeah anyway dude
jokes on that Jimmy Page Allen guy I
wonder who you're gonna see you're gonna
see Demi tomorrow
or the other Bruce Willis Scout three I
think he has four they have four
daughters together I don't know lemonade
is a popular drink and it still is I get
more props and stunts than Bruce Willis
okay shout out to Guru rest in peace oh
he's dead for a long long time damn rips
man so anyway was the man